what's your plan it's my plan and I
decide what goes down oh you got that
yeah my name is Joseph Aras and I'm the
writer director of a way out a way out
is a story-driven co-op game it is
designed played and experienced only in
split-screen co-op which means you have
to play the game with a friend either
online or on your couch the game starts
in a prison you play as Vincent L do you
and a friend will get to know your
characters and unfold their story
together you don't know anything about
me man
maybe not but Harvey kills someone very
close to me
with or without you I'm going after let
me show you some of the scenarios in the
game on the right side you see Leo was
already in prison on the left you see
Vincent who just arrived now if you look
to the right again you can see that Leo
can be controlled while Vincent is in a
cutscene here is another one Vincent
Alejo are now in the laundry room your
goal is to smuggle sheets using a
laundry cart you can approach the
scenario in different ways either get
the cart with Vincent you know I got a
good pack right here I think it's got
your name on it it's broken I don't know
or with Leo get over here you idiot yeah
but I think those two guys are just
about to fight ah what up what hip and a
way out you will experience something
new all the time everything you do in
the game is unique for that scene we
want you and your friend to be focused
and engaged throughout the entire story
but let me tell you this is just the
beginning of what you will be
experiencing in a way out
oh yeah
relax now I got this